نحن الان في مركز مدينه محمود هذه المدينه
التي تبدو الحياه وكانها قد توقفت في داخل
هذه المدينه المحرومه الان من كل الخدمات
الاساسيه ربما تلاحظون اصوات القصف لا
تتوقف في هذه المدينه كما قلنا لا يوجد ما
لا يوجد كهرباء لا يوجد غاز كل الخدمات
الاساسيه متوقفه في هذه المدينه التي تقصف
بشكل مستمر معظم المباني هنا اجزاء كبيره
من هذه المدينه تم قصفها على سبيل المثال
هذا هو احد الاسواق الرئيسيه المركزيه في
هذه المدينه قصف بعده صواريخ سقطت من جانب
القوات الروسيه التي لا تبعد بالمناسبه عن
هذه المدينه سوى تقريبا ثلاث او اربع كيلو
مترات العمليات العسكريه تقودها هنا في
هذه المنطقه قوات شركه فاجنر المعروفه
التي تحاول السيطره على هذه المدينه
المدينه الان شبه فارغه حاكم دونالدز يتهم
القوات الروسيه
بالتعمد باستهداف المدنيين في في المدينه
يقولون بانهم يحاولون ان يجلو من بقي
العداد القليله التي بقيت هنا يحاولون
الاجلاءها الى مناطق اكثر امنا واضح ان
هناك استماتا من قبل القوات الروسيه
للسيطره على هذه المدينه المهمه لماذا
لانها حاء السيطره على هذه المدينه تفتح
الطريق امام السيطره على مدن مهمه وسرته
واستراتيجيه اهمها طبعا مدينه
والعاصمه المؤقته لدونس واقصد هنا طبعا
مدينه الكرامه تورس عامل لا في الجزيره
ضخموت